[Music]
it's Kurdish in ketchup time
[Music]
Rob Kardashian and blac Chyna got a
little frisky on a snapchat the new mom
also shared these pics to Instagram
striking the sexy poses in a fishnet
bodysuit Khloe Kardashian got her sexy
on two at a Flashdance inspired a photo
shoot khlo money's hairstylist Jenna
Atkins shared a ton of snaps from the
shoot hello also stuns on the cover of
the latest issue of Health magazine and
inside she gushes over cutie boyfriend
Tristan Thompson
we have you met Tristan I have is he's a
wonderful guy I have met him he's great
and Courtney continued to celebrate
Suttons at Mason and rains of birthdays
Mason turned to 7 while rain is now -
the boys have a Disney filled day
Courtney Scott Disick and their kids
were all spotted at Disneyland on
Wednesday and Stan is an incredible
dancer
she's the greatest that night Kris
Jenner and company partied away at
family friend at Shelli Azoff Spig
Christmas bash at the Forum in Los
Angeles Kim Kardashian was spotted there
to a rare public outing for the star
following the Paris robbery
[Music]